the Christmas season is so special the
Traditions the meaning behind it
spending time with your family and
friends nothing is better than that and
tonight we are so blessed to have a very
special guest joining us all the way
from his Workshop it's the big man
himself Santa Claus so Santa Claus thank
you for joining us today people want to
know people people do know you as Santa
Claus but they also know that you go by
St Nicholas so how did you get that
name well that is correct so St Nicholas
I became a saint by qualifying a miracle
I used to be a bishop and I became a
saint when I cleared rough Seas so most
people don't realize I'm actually the
patron saint and
savior
fisherman yes that's right you were
originally from the country of now
that's Turkey um what great little
history you're offering us here on on on
your Legend and your life so tell us
this if somebody is on the not well
first let me ask you this what do you do
on your
offseason oh uh let's see so there are a
few places I like to visit especially
Florida so I actually spent some time
down there with some baby alligators
recently I think we have some pictures
of you in Florida don't
we yes you do you're catching some I had
such a good time
there who knew Santa love Florida as
much as the rest of us so Santa what do
we do somebody's on the naughty list
right now is it too late to get off and
what can they
do oh it's never too late there's always
a second chance available because in
actuality there's really not too many
naughty kids there's mostly
misunderstood ones so just like when I
used to give coal people thought that
was a punishment but back then all the
homes were heated with coal so that was
a second chance for those children to to
give that coal to their families to help
them Heat their home I didn't know that
that's so awesome okay well Santa
everyone knows that you're partial to
cookies you like cookies and lots of
kids leave you cookies but what if the
kids want to leave something for the
reindeer what should they leave for the
reindeer my reindeer really like carrots
they like raw ones not so much cooked
ones they also like you take dry oats
and sprinkle it with cinnamon but my
favorite is whenever I get a broken
candy cane and there's a child upset
with that I remind them very special
because I take the broken ones I crush
them up into little pieces and I give
them to the reindeers a little special
treat oh I love that you don't waste a
thing okay so how do you fit down the
chimney you know and so and what do you
do if people don't have a
chimney well fitting down the chimney is
a little easy with some Christmas magic
but if I don't have a chimney to go down
and I don't have a fireplace well that's
when my magic key comes into
place ah
a magic golden key I love
it okay last question really quick S I
know you're so busy this time of year
what's your favorite Christmas
movie oh this might surprise everyone my
all-time favorite Christmas movie is
actually a Flintstones Christmas
Carol that's a good choice my favorite
Miracle on 34th Street and It's a
Wonderful Life Santa it is great to have
you here today um all the little kids
are waiting for you I know you're so
busy what are you doing next what's the
really quick what are you doing right
now finishing all the that I can and
then taking my big trip around the
entire world to see all of you and leave
something special underneath your
tree well Santa thank you for taking
time out of your busy schedule to talk
to us Merry Christmas and good luck over
the next days hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now